على اعتاب الشهر الثاني من المواجهات
العسكريه تتواصل الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع مدينه
الخرطوم بحري تصدرت المشهد بعد عمليه
عسكريه عنيفه حيث قرر الجيش مهاجمه مواقع
تمركز الدعم السريع هجوم الجيش في الخرطوم
بحري ياتي لمواجهه تمدد الدعم السريع
وانتشاره في المدينه فالمواجهه العنيفه
كانت في عده محاور لا سيما شامبات الحله
والبرا وشرق النيل وشارع الانقاذ مقاتله
الجيش نفذت غارات على اهداف للدعم السريع
خصوصا في شنبات فيما قال الدعم السريع انه
سيطر على جسر الحلفايه شمال الخرطوم بحري
كما اعلن عن اسقاط طائرتين للجيش اما في
وسط الخرطوم تجددت الاشتباكات في مشنت
مقاتلات الجيش ضربات جويه استهدفت ايضا
محيط القصر الرئاسي
وفي ام درمان وقعت اشتباكات بين طرفي
الصراع وسمع ذوي قذائفي مدفعيه
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات